let's go next to our caller from the
7:00 to 4:00 area code who's calling
today from 7:00 to 4:00 what they going
on Dave hey who's this can you hear me
my name is bird hey bird what's up oh
not much
I enjoyed that last bit yeah sort of all
right my question would be why does the
press corps when they're listening to
Donald Trump and he's just blabbing on
or when he personally attacks him yep
why don't they grow the balls and
actually snap back at him why are they
just sitting there hanging their heads
and letting him ramble yeah I know what
you mean I would love I mean so so
here's the thing there's a balance first
of all even if you have a president who
has thrown all guidelines of decorum
into the trash the press corps is still
relatively collegial and they have a
code of conduct and they are journalists
and they sort of abide by it like they
don't throw their code of conduct out
the window just because Trump does what
I would like to see is when like - a
couple days ago Trump said I'm
withholding money from the w-h-o five
minutes later someone said is that a
good idea and he said I never said I was
withholding money from the w-h-o I would
like to see everybody in the room read
the quote back to him and confront him
with it but the the reality but if you
call great thing if you called on ones
like all Trump out on a lie he'll tell
three more lies and it branches virally
so I don't really know that you get
anywhere I feel like it's it's kind of
it's almost a lost cause it may seem
that way I guess yeah I don't understand
it myself personally I'm not a
journalist I don't think I could
personally sit there and listen and talk
without saying something you know and
maybe they should maybe they should they
should push harder maybe they'll draw
them out the real Donald Trump you know
because there's this Bush persona he
puts on now
you know act ID healing enact percentage
presidential now you know so but I think
if they pushed him a little harder you
know he you know he bites nap and what I
agree whatever the long meltdown when
Trump does get pushed a little more or
he gets asked what he considers a nasty
question he does snap he starts pointing
at reporters and saying you're a
third-rate journalist you should be
ashamed of yourself
you're never gonna succeed that's the
realest Trump that we ever see and he
very quickly snaps and that's what he's
known for doing in private with his own
employees and people who work for him
like I believe that's the closest to the
real Trump we ever see and I love that
the fact that he calls every honest
question like a you know it's a
legitimate question how can you call it
nasty especially when they're quoting
him yeah
no no so here's the code in vacuum if
Trump says that's a beautiful question
it's a soft ball usually from Oh a n
right
if Trump says the question is nasty or
that the journalist should be ashamed of
themselves that's the thread you want to
be pulling on because you're actually
getting it something Trump doesn't want
to talk about in their praise is so
blatant yeah I mean everybody else in
the room turns and look at it because
there's gonna go no mr. president
you're so strong you're so big and
strong that's the way it goes yeah when
you see the absolutely kill me who the
hell is asking that it's usually because
it's Oh a and asking some brown-nosing
question well he loves praise he does
certainly does bird thank you for the
call very much appreciate it